Still not familiar with international competition
most prestigious in the world of youth marketing
talents?
We tell you about it and in 1 word it is described as
impressive.
In this competition
we challenge customer teams
to develop 1 Griffin
perfect in 48 hours,
which will later be
exposed and reviewed by 1 exceptional group of mathematicians
who will act as an agency and value the work.
If you are between 18 and 30 years old,
you work in the department
of communication
or marketing of 1 advertiser and you have 1 duo,
it's your time!
Sign up before March 21
and you will have the possibility
to represent Spain in the international championship
iracans in 2,024